The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Right, OK.
So I think this was
where we were up to.
I wasn't here last time,
so I don't really know.
But George told me that
this was where you're up to,
so that's where I'm
going to carry on from.
And so this section is all
about imaging and resolution,
and it starts off
here looking in
some strange American
dictionary at the definition
of a "resolution."
Of course, myself,
coming from Oxford,
I would always use
the Oxford Dictionary.
I don't know what that says.
But anyway, this is
quite interesting.
The verb here, resolve, "to
break up its constituent parts,
to analyze, to
find an answer to,
to solve, determine, and
decide," blah, blah, blah.
But anyway, I think this first
part is-- the very first thing
is a good one, isn't it?
So break up into its
constituent parts.
So you look at an
image, and you've
got to actually determine
what the different parts
of the image really mean.
And if they sort
of merge together,
you won't be able
to resolve what
the image is trying to say.
So that's what it means.
And yeah, now, there are
lots of different ways
of determining resolution,
different definitions
that people apply.
The most used one, perhaps, is
the Rayleigh resolution limit,
which was proposed
by Lord Rayleigh.
Lord Rayleigh was very
interested in astronomy,
and so he was interested
in trying to quantify
the imaging of stars.
So if you look up in
the telescope at the sky
and you've got two stars
very close together,
then you'll see, like the
two images of the stars,
this shows to two different
separations of those two
points.
And now, it's important to
note that stars, of course,
two independent stars
would be completely
incoherent with
respect to each other
because they obviously
don't know-- the one doesn't
know what the other's doing.
So they emit light incoherently
with respect to each other.
So to calculate the image
of these two points,
you have to add together the
intensities of the two images,
and that's what this shows here.
And so this shows
two different spaces.
And this one here,
this is what I
think is really normally taken
as the Rayleigh resolution
limit.
I don't know about
this other one.
I don't where Georgia
has got this from,
but he talks about these
two different limits
in these notes.
So in this one here, you'll
see that this peak here
is placed exactly over
the 0 of the other,
the first 0 of the other image.
So that's what defines
this separation shown
in this picture.
And we find that if they're
separated by that amount,
the total image is
given by this blue line.
We get that just by adding
together the two intensities
of the two points together.
And you can see that this
drops a bit at the center.
What is it?
I think the intensity
there is 0.888--
I can't remember now.
No, it doesn't matter.
But anyway, it's
about 0.8, isn't it?
0.835, so that figure sounds--
But anyway, the other
interesting thing, of course,
is that because this
one is 0 at this point,
it means that this maximum is 1.
It's exactly 1.
It's just the one point
with no contribution
from the other one.
Anyway, so that is
arbitrarily taken
as being the definition of
the point being just resolved.
So we say that if there are
any closer together than that,
you can't resolve them.
You would see a little
bit of a dip still,
but we say that the dips not
really big enough for you
to really be confident that
there are two objects there.
And if you make
them further apart,
then, of course, they'll
become more distinguished.
And this shows an example
here where you can see now,
this is twice the separation.
So this is where the PSF
diameter equals the point
source spacing.
So the-- what does
he mean by that?
Sorry.
This one, the PSF radius equals
the point source spacing.
Yeah, OK.
So that is the distance
between the center of the image
And the first dark ring.
In this one, the PSF diameter
equals the point source
spacing.
Has he got this right?
No, it's not the second zero.
It's not at the second zero
exactly, anymore, is it?
So the spacing here is
twice the spacing there.
Anyway, I think that's what
I'm taking at this meaning.
But as Charlene
just pointed out,
that means this is not
actually at a zero.
This is not placed at a
zero of this other one
because, if you remember,
the zeros of the Airy disk
are irregularly
spaced, aren't they?
So they're not equally spaced,
like the light for a sink.
And so because this isn't
0 at this point here,
this maximum here
will be not exactly 1.
It will be slightly more than 1.
OK.
And if this condition is
satisfied, then, in this case,
the delta R, the--
where does he define that?
That's the-- I guess it's
this distance here, isn't it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's the
separation of the peaks.
Yeah, OK, it's the
It's 0.61 lambda over NA.
Oh, yeah.
OK.
So here he's--
R and R dashed are obviously
coordinates in the object
played in the image
plane, effectively.
Yeah.
So, of course, it depends on--
the numerical aperture
in those two spaces
won't be the same, of course.
But there will be
magnification as well, which
is going to mean that
you get the same answer
for the resolution
in both planes.
So this 0.61 is
this magic figure
that comes about
basically because of the--
it's related to the first zero
of the Bessel function, j1.
And the first zero of the
Bessel function j1 is 3.83,
and this is 3.83
divided by 2 pi.
Does that sound right?
Yeah.
Yeah, I think that sounds right.
This one here is
twice the spacing,
so 1.22 lambda over NA.
So this is 3.83 divided by pi.
Yeah.
So here, actually,
these are obviously
extremely well resolved.
You wouldn't have
any problem in seeing
that there's two points there.
And so here he calls these two
definitions the safe definition
and the pushy definition.
My experience is that
the pushy definition
is the one that is
normally quoted in places,
and so this is this one
where you can only just see
a bit of a dip in between them.
Note that if we did the same
thing for the 1D system, i.e.
for a slit aperture rather
than a circular aperture, then
you'd be looking at the
first zero of a sink rather
than a Bessel function.
And so you get these expressions
rather than these, so 1.22
rather than 1 or
0.61 rather than 0.5.
So in this case you
actually you can
see you can resolve
slightly smaller spacing
with a slit aperture than
with a circular aperture.
And this is a true effect
that sometimes people
try to take advantage of.
You will see that
different authors
give different definitions.
So I'm not going to go into
all that because it's not
really important at this stage.
Rayleigh, in his original
paper, noted the issue of noise
and warned that the definition
of just resolvable points
is system or
application dependent.
Actually, what you find--
well, a lot of that
is true, of course.
Here we're-- it very much
depends on the actual system
and what you're trying to
measure all these sorts
of things.
And you can come up with
lots of different resolution
criteria for different
shaped objects,
and the comparison
of different systems
doesn't always give
the same answers
according to what you chose.
So beware.
There is not one answer to
this question of resolution.
The other thing is,
as he says here,
is noise is an important
thing, of course.
If you add noise
to these image--
we've got some
examples later where
there's noise
added to the images
so that you can see
what it does to it.
But one thing that is perhaps
not quite what George is saying
there-- actually, you do find--
if you look at the image
of these two points,
as you bring them
together, you actually
do find that the
degradation in the image
is really rather sudden.
So although, OK, it's
not a specific point,
it is quite so sudden.
And so you'll find that if
you change the separation
around slightly more or
slightly less than that,
you'd find that this central
bit would go up and down quite
a lot, actually.
So it is quite a sensitive
change around that spacing.
So that gives us some idea
that maybe this resolution
limit as it's defined does
mean something, anyway.
Now, that's for a perfect
aberration-free system.
But very often,
you've got systems
where you've got aberrations,
and that's obviously
going to mean that
the resolution is not
going to be as good.
So this picture shows
an example with coma.
So this is with an off-axis
ray, off-axis beam going
through a lens, and you
get this coma spot here.
So now, of course,
this spot is bigger
than it would be if there
were no aberrations,
and therefore you'd expect that
the resolution would be worse.
So this is another thing you
have to take into account.
I don't think there's going
to be much more about that.
But did that do something there?
Or perhaps this didn't
push it fast enough.
Now, the other way of
looking at the effects--
resolution and the
effects of aberrations
is looking at the transfer
function approach.
And so this is giving results
for a one-dimensional system.
And it you see it's an MTF,
Modulation Transfer Function.
So that means it's
an incoherent system.
The MTF is the Fourier transform
of the point spread function.
So this is for the
aberration-free case.
This is a sink squared,
the point spread
function for the 1D case.
And if you take the
Fourier transform,
you get the modulation
transfer function,
as he calls it, and
vise versa, of course.
These are Fourier
transform pairs.
This is just a
triangle function.
And this shows what
would happen if you
got some aberrations there.
In general, what would happen
is that this would be broader,
and this would be deformed
so that you've got a lower
spatial frequency response.
Here, actually, he seems to
be showing something which
has got an improved response
at the very high frequencies,
which is quite interesting
because what that would mean,
actually, is that
if your object only
had those high
spatial frequencies,
the system with aberrations
would actually give a better
image than the one
without aberrations.
So maybe that's a bit anomalous.
So now some common
misinterpretations,
attempting to resolve
object feature smaller
than the resolution limit, i.e.
1.22 lambda over
NA, is hopeless.
So he's saying that
that's not strictly true
because this is
not, for a start,
it's not a sudden cutoff.
And it depends on the presence
of noise and other features.
So there is a very big no to
say that, yes, you can sometimes
see things which are smaller
than the resolution limit.
And then also another
point is that there
are ways you can actually
improve the performance using,
for example, the
CLEAN algorithm.
The CLEAN algorithm is a
thing they use in astronomy
for doing deconvolution.
It works particularly well--
it would be very good, actually,
for some of these microscope
things that people do nowadays
with these very sparse
molecules because
it's designed to work
with you know in astronomy
with isolated point images.
So if it looks at
a continuous object
like a motorcar or something
like that, it wouldn't work.
It would actually only
work on point-type images.
Then vena filtering-- we'll
say something more about that--
expectation,
maximization, et cetera.
So there are various digital
ways you can improve the image
and get information
out of the image,
even if you can't see
it by [INAUDIBLE]..
And then there's this other
word, super-resolution.
Super-resolution,
it means, basically,
getting better resolution
than you are suppose to, i.e.
beating the Rayleigh
diffraction limit.
And various ways have been
proposed for doing this.
And until recently,
I guess, most of them
were pretty unsuccessful.
But more recently, nowadays,
some of these techniques
are doing really well.
I think the most
noticeable one probably
is STED, Stimulated Emission
Depletion, microscopy,
where Stefan Hell is
getting resolutions which,
I don't know, more than a factor
of 10 better than you should
according to the Rayleigh
diffraction limit.
But anyway, here he's
talking about what are
called super-resolving filters.
What you do is you alter the
pupil function of the lens
by some clever trick in order
to sharpen up the point spread
function.
And I think that maybe George
did mention that earlier
on at some point.
But the problem is
what always happens
is that it doesn't actually--
you never get
anything for nothing.
That's the problem.
You make a central
lobe narrower,
but you find that the side
lobes become stronger.
And the other thing is that
very often the power transmitted
through the system
is much reduced.
So you can imagine if
you've got some filter that
absorbs part of the power,
then you're wasting power.
So both of these can be bad.
And so, consequently, this
idea of super-resolving filters
in practice has never
really, up until now,
been very successful from
a practical point of view.
But anyway, this
shows one example.
This shows a circular pupil.
And yeah, and then this
one is an annual pupil,
which you can model as
being one circular function
minus another one.
And of course, once you
write it in that simple way,
as a circ function, as
the difference between two
circ functions, you can do the
Fourier transform with that
very easily and get the point
spread function of these two
cases very easily.
And so he's working it out for
a focal length of 20 centimeters
and a wavelength of 0.5 microns.
And the width of
that aperture is--
what is it?
It looks about 4 millimeters
diameter, something like that.
Yeah.
Anyway, so this is-- and he
works out what it looks like.
So this is the PSF.
This is supposed
to be an Airy disk.
It's been sampled
a bit coarsely,
so it looks a bit ragged.
And so what you see is when
you look at the annular case,
you put this central
obscuration in the center
there, what it does is it
narrows up that central lobe.
And you can see, though,
it also increases
the strength of
these side lobes,
that these are much
higher than these ones.
So although in some cases
this can give a good
an improved image compared
with this, for example,
for point objects
it would do well,
but if you've got
an extended object
like an image of a
car or something,
it might not work so well.
The other way of thinking on
it is in terms of the MTF.
And this is our normal
MTF for a circular pupil.
It's this so-called
Chinese hat function.
And then for the annular
pupil, this is what you get.
You remember, you
calculate these.
This is the convolution, the
autocorrelation of a circle.
So you have to--
you get two circles
and you displace
it one relative to the other.
You calculate the
area of overlap,
and you plot the area of overlap
as a function of the distance
between the two center.
So that's how you
actually calculate this.
And you do the
same with this one,
and you can see what you
get is you see that it drops
more quickly, first of all.
This is normalized to
1 because you normally
normalize transfer functions
to 1 for 0 spatial frequencies.
That's the way we
normally do it.
But I guess maybe it's not
the only way of doing it.
This drops down quickly
because you can see,
if you're working out the
autocorrelation at this angular
aperture, you can
see that [INAUDIBLE]
you move it a small amount,
the one the one bright region
is not going to overlap
with the other one anymore.
So that's why it drops
off quickly there.
And then it has
another blip out here,
which basically comes about
from when the toe annularly--
where they both got their bright
bits on top of each other.
And so if you compare
this one with this one,
you can see that here the
spatial frequency response
is much lower.
Here, actually,
it can be higher.
The cutoff of course,
is still the same.
So you could calculate
the image of any object
you fancied from knowing that.
And this is another example.
This is the case of a
Gaussian apodization.
So what we're now
doing is instead of--
the annulus is
effectively boosting up
the edges of the
pupil, which is why
you get this improved high
spatial frequency response.
Here we're doing the
opposite of that.
apodization-- if George was
here, he would tell us--
in fact, he already did it
one of the previous lectures--
apodization means to cut off
the feet in Greek, I believe.
He'll probably be listening
to my lecture and tell me
I've got my Greek all wrong.
But anyway, it's to do--
it means to cut off the feet.
And what it means, why
it's given that name,
is because it cuts
off the side lobes.
So you see the side lobes of the
Airy disk have disappeared now.
So by making this shaded
aperture-- in this case,
is a Gaussian function--
you make something
which is a bit broader.
Actually, in this case, doesn't
look very much broader at all.
But the side lobes
have gone, and this
is what it's done to
the transfer function.
You see now it's slower to
fall off here than this one.
But the high spatial frequencies
are now reduced relative
to this other one.
So overview on this, then.
This is what we call--
or what George is calling
pupil engineering.
And so if you try to make
the main, the central lobe
of the PSF smaller, then you're
going to get bigger side lobes.
And that seems to be something
that you can't avoid.
Nobody's come up with a way
of doing something clever that
avoids that.
And the opposite,
of course, if you
make the main side lobe bigger,
the side lobes get smaller.
No doubt, that is maybe not so
necessarily going to happen.
I suspect that if
you really wanted,
you could probably
make something
that had a big central
lobe and big side lobes.
But nobody would really
want that anyway.
And then also this
power loss problem,
that there is going to be some
worse signal-to-noise sort
of performance.
So annular-type pupils
typically narrow the main lobe
at the point spread function at
the expense of high side lobes.
Gaussian-type pupil
functions typically
suppress the side lobes
but broaden the main lobe.
And so, as it says
here, different sorts
of filters like
this might possibly
be worth considering for
certain particular applications.
Yeah, and then he
gives another couple
of problems with these things.
Making a filter which is of
varying amplitude is not easy.
And I guess nowadays you might
do it with some liquid crystal
device, hopefully.
We might be doing that
so, won't we, Charlene?
But until recently,
this would have
to have been done by some sort
of photolithographic process.
And actually getting controlling
the absorption of the filter
to accurately fit what you
designed is not trivial.
And there's also this
energy loss problem, then.
Yeah, nowadays people are very
interested in phase filters.
You can do a lot of
these clever things
also by using phase masks
rather than amplitude masks.
And of course, a phase apodizer
is going to be lossless.
So that might make
it sound attractive.
And so George says that
maybe it is attractive.
Actually, it turns out, I think,
it's not quite as attractive
as it might sound
because, actually,
very often what happens is if
you use an absorbing filter,
the absorption that you
can introduce actually
can reduce the size
of the side lobes.
So if you do it
cleverly, you might
be able to make the side
lobes lower and also
still get as much energy
into the central lobe with it
with an absorbing mask as
with a pure phase mask.
Yeah, and then we get on
to all these terminologies
that is obviously
annoyed by as much as me.
This is one.
This super cool digital
camera has a resolution
of eight megapixels.
And so what's he going
to say about this?
Big no again.
So this is using
the word wrongly.
This has nothing to
do with resolution.
And so what they are
actually referring
to is the space bandwidth
product of the camera, how
many pixels there
are, which is not
really measured as resolution.
The other one, as all
the people in my group
would know that I always
get very cross about,
is these interferometry
people who are always
talking about
inerferometers being
able to resolve one
Angstrom, which is also wrong
because it's nothing
about resolving.
So resolving, resolution, we've
said what resolution means.
So this question of
the number of pixels,
is there a connection
between the two?
Well, I guess the answer is,
there is and there isn't.
There is a relationship if
you design the optical system
properly.
But what George is
pointing out here
is that, actually, this is an
example where the pixels are
very much smaller
than the point spread
function of the optical system.
So actually, here you're very
much over sampling this image.
So all you're measuring--
you're measuring very accurately
a blurred picture.
So that's not really giving
you very good resolution
and not really very--
the number of resolution
elements in your image
is actually much smaller then
than the number of pixels.
Sometimes they use
this word resels,
don't they, resolution elements.
Have you seen that?
They spell it R-E-S-E-L. It's
an abbreviation for resolution
elements, so it's the number
of resolved spots you've got
in your device rather
than the number of pixels.
Some more misstatements--
it is pointless to attempt
to resolve beyond the Rayleigh
criterion, however defined.
No, the difficulty
increases gradually as
feature sizes shrink, and
difficulty is noise dependent.
So it's not a sharp
hard and fast line.
But that said, I think
you I think it probably
would be pointless
to attempt to resolve
10 times the Rayleigh limit
with an ordinary optical system
because you know you're not
going to be able to do that.
But STED, that we were talking
about earlier, does do that.
So this is [INAUDIBLE]
well, OK, so maybe it
is worth attempting to do it
because people have come up
with ways of doing it now.
Apodization can be used to beat
the resolution limit imposed
by the numerical aperture.
And there's a big
no there again.
Watch the side lobe growth
and poor efficiency loss.
I don't know if you've noticed,
but I spoke to one of--
maybe Charlene-- I
can't remember now.
There was a paper in Nature
Methods recently by Nikolai
[? Segilev, ?] where
he gave an example
of a super-resolving
mask, and he gave the pic
this picture of a very
narrow point spread function,
improving on the Rayleigh
rate resolution limit
by a factor of, I don't
know, a few, I think.
But I did some calculations
on the design he gave.
It turned out that this
little central peak
was surrounded by side
lobes that went up
to something like 10 to
the power of 40-something
or something really ridiculous.
And the amount of energy that
went into this central spot
was, like, nothing.
And what made it even worse
was that if you actually
calculated what happened
as you went out of focus,
you found that you also got
these big walls around it, very
high all around it, actually.
So it was this like this very
small bright spot completely
surrounded by something
which was, like,
10 to the 40 times higher.
So how you would ever
use that in practice, you
can think it really
obviously wouldn't
be a very practical device.
Then the number of the rest
of the pixels in your camera
is not the resolution.
So what is resolution?
Our ability to resolve to point
objects based on the image.
However, this may be
difficult to quantify.
Resolution is related
to the NA, i.e.
it's proportional to the NA.
The distance is inversely
proportional to the NA.
That's another thing
that people sometimes
get into knots about of
course because resolution
means that the
bigger the number,
the more is the resolution.
But actually, the smaller the
size, the more the resolution,
so beware.
So sometimes, actually, people
use the term "resolving power"
to get around that problem
because otherwise-- people
say things which they don't
really mean sometimes.
Yeah, so other factors
that can affect
resolution-- aberrations,
apodization, and noise.
So is there an easy answer?
When in doubt, quote,
0.61 lambda over NA.
And then you get the
marks in the exam.
So that's that one done.
So how are we going?
Got a bit more time yet.
That was last week's lecture
I just gave then, anyway.
So I think it must be this one.
So I don't know how far we're
going to get with this one,
but we can at least start it.
So what we're supposed
to be doing today,
more applications
of the transfer
function, a bit
about depth of focus,
and a bit about deconvolution.
And there's some
nice simulations
that George is
done to show that.
And then he's got down
for Wednesday, which
I'm also going to be giving.
I think George is not back.
Do you know when
George comes back?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
Anyway, so I shall be giving
the lecture on Wednesday.
And so polarization-- what
we don't finish from today
will obviously also
be on Wednesday,
and then there's polarization,
intensity distribution
near the focus of
high-NA imaging systems.
And yeah, I don't know what else
we're going to do, actually,
because George keeps changing
his mind about what we ought
to put in that last lecture.
So defocus.
So this is an
example of defocus.
Anyone know what this movie is?
I don't.
I'm out of touch with cinema.
Recognize who the
other stars are?
No?
No.
I'm only asking
because I just did--
AUDIENCE: It's Fight Club.
PROFESSOR: Is that right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Anyway, what you'll
notice is this guy here--
is it a guy?
I can't really recognize
what it is, actually.
But it's out of focus.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it could be.
OK, so anyway, so that's
an example of defocus.
Then this is what
happens when you
get a lens in the
proximal approximation
and look at the intensity
in the focal region.
You get something that
looks a bit like that.
It doesn't look quite
the same as [INAUDIBLE]..
I don't know how George
did this calculation.
But you'll notice that
this is the focal plane,
so this is a cross section
through the Airy disk.
So you see the central--
ah, well, I can tell you
why it's different, then.
You can see these have got
its regularly spaced zeros.
So he's done this through
a slit aperture, hasn't he?
And so that might explain
why it looks a bit different.
But what you'll see--
excuse me-- is that as
you go out of focus--
well, note one thing.
It's symmetrical
about the focal plan.
And this is--
I think we probably had that
somewhere before, actually,
that it's symmetrical.
If it's calculated using the
usual Debye approximation,
you get a result like that.
So if you've got, for
example, the aperture stop
is in the front focal
plane of the lens
and you look at what happens
in the back focal plane, then
that would be the case.
You get this symmetrical
behavior like this.
And you can see also
these sort of bright bands
that seem to go off at
diagonal lines here.
I guess, yeah, so that
corresponds roughly
to the edge of the
aperture then, of course.
And yeah, so the width of the
central spot in this direction,
then, we've said is this
0.61 lambda over NA,
and this distance from
the focal plane where
you get to this
first zero is given
by some expression like this.
It goes as if--
this is really only
true for the paraxial case.
But for the paraxial
case, this NA
here, NA squared here, if it's
the high aperture case, which
we might consider
on Wednesday, you'll
find that this is not
quite right anymore.
Yeah, so delta x is
the radial resolution.
Delta z is the depth of focus,
today's topics, depth of focus
or depth of field.
And both of those he calls DoF.
Note the very high
numerical apertures.
The scalar approximation
is no longer good.
The vectorial nature of
the electromagnetic field
becomes important.
That is true.
There's other things
as well, though.
When you do all this paraxial
stuff, if you remember,
all the time you're replacing
sine theta by theta and things
like that, making
approximations like that.
So there are actually lots
of approximations you make.
One is the fact that
the angles are small.
The other is that you neglect
the polarization effects.
When the apertures become big,
then the polarization effects
become very important.
So we're going to look
at this sort of system.
And so this is a 4F
system with magnification,
so the two the focal
length of the two lenses
are different in this case.
And so this shows
what happens if you're
looking at an object which is
placed a distance F in front
of this lens and your screen
is placed the difference F2
behind this lens,
and your aperture
is F1 from this one
and F2 from this one.
So everything there
is set up properly
as defined for a 4F system.
And this is the case
where you'd expect,
as I was just describing, the
defocus point spread function
is going to be symmetric.
So we place our mask there,
and we've got our pupil.
So this is our object function.
This is the angular
spectrum, the spectrum
of the object in
this plane here,
which is then filtered
by the aperture stop.
And then that gives some sort
of amplitude in this plane
here, which is
going to be inverted
and also magnified or
otherwise according
to the ratio of F1 over F2.
And there's the rays
going through it.
And this is showing how--
yeah, this plane, this
is his terminology.
This is x.
This is x prime.
This is x double prime.
And you can see here x
double prime maximum is
equal to the and the
radius of the aperture.
So this is his terminology.
We are going to get that in
a minute coming [INAUDIBLE]..
This is a function of x This is
a function of x double prime.
This is a function of x prime.
This is the numerical
aperture of the lens
that's looking at it.
And yeah, so the
numerical aperture
is equal to x double
prime maximum, which
is equal to A over F1, again
assuming that the sine theta
or tan theta are both theta.
Now, what we're
going to look at now
is what happens if we
defocus this system.
So now our object has been
displaced the distance delta
away, and we want to calculate
what the image of that
looks like now.
And so what we can say
is that after we've
eliminated this
object, we've got
this GT of x, and then
that light is going
to propagate from here to here.
And in order to
calculate that, we
have to convolve it with
the propagation kernel.
So you convolve it
with this thing.
For some reason, when George
converted this from his
whatever his other
thing's called, keynotes--
it's a PowerPoint.
All the equations are
like as though someone's
had their martinis
before the lecture.
So we then look at the Fourier
transform of that in this plane
here.
So this thing convolves--
Fourier transforms to this.
The convolution
transforms to a product,
and this Gaussian transforms
to another Gaussian.
And notice that, as
usual, of course,
you remember that the
scaling thing for Fourier
transforms, the
bigger a function is,
the smaller it's Fourier
transform and vice versa.
So this lambda delta at the
bottom appears now at the top.
So the bigger delta
is, the bigger
this thing's going to be here.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is E to the
imaginary x squared a Gaussian?
Or only the E to the real
x squared a Gaussian?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Yeah, the real Gaussian is E to
the minus x squared, isn't it?
E to the minus x
squared does that.
This is what you might
call an imaginary Gaussian.
But it all comes out
in the wash, actually.
So just the same as
the Fourier transform
of the normal Gaussian
is another Gaussian,
so the Fourier transform
of this imaginary Gaussian
is another imaginary Gaussian.
So what's really converting
is a parabolic phase front
here to a parabolic
phase front here.
So you can get it just by
getting the normal expression.
I mean, it sometimes amazes
me having how much liberties
you can take with these things.
But you just take the
expressions for the Gaussian,
and you put in this
complex number,
and it gives the right answer.
So it's very nice.
I guess occasionally
there might be
occasions when it doesn't work.
Yeah, so what he's then saying
is that you can think of this--
this is the object for our--
this is the spectrum for
our defocused objects,
which is multiplied by the
pupil function of the system.
But that is exactly
equivalent of course
to thinking of it as
the ordinary object
spectrum multiplied by a
modified pupil function.
So it doesn't matter whether
you associate this with this
or with the pupil function.
So that's what we can think of.
We can think of the objects
as being the same as where
it is if it wasn't
defocused, and we
can think of the pupil
function of the thing being
modified to take into
account of defocus.
We sometimes called that the
defocus transfer function.
And so he's now going
to calculate that.
Yeah, so the defocus--
he calls it here the defocus
amplitude transfer function.
So remember, here
we're dealing--
this is dealing now
with coherent system.
Before, when we were
doing the resolution,
we were looking at
incoherent systems.
So now we've gone back
to coherent systems.
So you have to be wary of
that because sometimes there's
some differences.
So all this is saying then--
yeah, you remember,
to go from the front
the pupil to the transfer
function, all you have to do
is a coordinate scaling.
So the amplitude
transfer function
is just the scaled version
of this pupil function.
And again, it comes out
to be now, of course--
it's going to be--
it's multiplied, of course,
still by the circular aperture.
But inside that
circular aperture
where it's got some
value, its value
is given by this
complex exponential--
a complex Gaussian, like
we were just saying before.
And that's what this looks like.
Now, notice, so this is cosine.
This is looking at
just the real part.
So actually, it was a complex--
it was an E to the
minus I something.
So you can break that
up into cos plus I sine.
And the cos part
is the real part,
and the sine part is
the imaginary part.
And as when we looked
at imaging earlier,
the real part
images real objects.
So an amplitude object will
be imaged by the real part.
A phase object would be
imaged by the imaginary part.
But we're not going to
say anything about that.
We'll just keep
with the real part.
So this is cos, but
it's not a normal cos.
It's cos of an x squared.
So that's why it looks a
rather strange shape compared
with the normal cosine.
You can see it's
become very flat there,
and then it becomes more
oscillating later on.
And so this is
what it looks like.
Of course, the actual
scaling of this
is going to depend on
the value of this delta.
So here he looks at where
this crosses the axis.
So this parameter, x double
prime over lambda F1,
is equal to u, the
spatial frequency.
So this is just u squared here.
And he says that this crosses
the axis where this argument is
equal to pi over 2.
And if you solve
that, you'll get this.
And so that's where
it crosses the axis.
And then you have to
multiply this, of course,
by the circular aperture.
So this is the
circular aperture.
This is the radium where the
object spectrum is non-zero.
And so you can see
that only the parts
of this blue curve up to here
are going to have any meaning.
The bits out here are
not going to do anything.
So this is obviously
looking at a case
where this is almost flat.
If you made it a bit
smaller, even, it
would look even flatter.
So this is a not
a lot of defocus.
And so here he's
got, then-- yeah,
so here now is labeling
where that cutoff is.
So this is equal to NA
over lambda, as we know.
And in terms of the
x prime coordinate,
it's given right
by this thing here.
So this is talking about
what he calls mild defocus,
and the condition
for that to occur
is that this has got to
be much smaller than this.
And then-- yeah, and
that corresponds, then,
in terms of delta.
So we've now got a condition
for this to happen.
The value of delta has
to be small compared
with lambda over 2 NA squared.
So you remember,
this is what we said
was the depth of field or
depth of focus of the system.
Depth of field is measured
in the object space.
It doesn't say anything about
the defocus on that one.
I thought I was
going to [INAUDIBLE]..
He says a bit about that later.
This is showing
another case, then.
This is with much
more defocus now.
So now it's oscillating
a lot more wildly,
so now this cutoff is
much smaller than this.
And so this is where you've
got a lot of defocus.
And the fact that
this goes negative
is probably the worst thing.
It means that some
spatial frequencies
are going to be imaged
with the wrong contrast.
So when you try doing
your Fourier synthesis
to add up to make the image,
it's not going to work right.
And the other point he makes is
that the regions around here,
of course, these spatial
frequencies around these zeros
are not imaged at all.
So that's another reason why it
doesn't give a very good image.
So this is the case of
strongly focus where delta
is much bigger than this thing,
not necessarily much bigger,
I suppose.
I think we ought to stop there.
We've run over time anyway.
So let's stop at this point and
we'll pick that up next time.